Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I am stunned by this new graphics paper that
promises to simulate three-way coupling and
enables beautiful surface tension simulations
like this, and this, and more.
Yes, none of this is real footage, these are
all simulated on a computer.
I have seen quite a few simulations, and I
am still baffled by this.
How is this even possible?
Also, three-way coupling, eh?
That is quite peculiar, to the point that
the term doesn’t even sound real.
Let’s find out why together.
So, what does that mean exactly?
Well, first, let’s have a look at one way
coupling.
As the box moves here, it has an effect on
the smoke plume around it.
This example also showcases one-way coupling,
where the falling plate stirs up the smoke
around it.
And now, on to two-way coupling.
In this case, similarly to the previous ones,
the boxes are allowed to move the smoke, but
the added two-way coupling part means that
now, the smoke is also allowed to blow away
the boxes.
What’s more, the vortices here on the right
were even able to suspend the red box in the
air for a few seconds.
An excellent demonstration of a beautiful
phenomenon.
So, coupling means interaction between different
kinds of objects.
And two-way coupling seems like the real deal.
Here, it is also required to compute how this
fiery smoke trail propels the rocket upward.
But wait, we just mentioned that the new method
performs three-way coupling.
Two-way was solid-fluid interactions, and
it seemed absolutely amazing, so what is the
third element then?
And why do we even need that?
Well, depending on what object is in contact
with the liquid, gravity, buoyancy, and surface
tension forces need additional considerations.
To be able to do this, now look carefully!
Yes, there is the third element, it simulates
this thin liquid membrane too, which is in
interaction with the solid and the fluid at
the same time.
And with that, please meet three-way coupling!
So, what can it do?
It can simulate this paperclip floating on
water.
That is quite remarkable because the density
of the paperclip is 8 times as much as the
water itself, and yet, it still sits on top
of the water.
But how is that possible?
Especially given that gravity wants to constantly
pull down a solid object.
Well, it has two formidable opponents, two
forces that try to counteract it, one is buoyancy,
which is an upward force, and two, the capillary
force, which is a consequence of the formation
of a thin membrane.
If these two friends are as strong as gravity,
the object will float.
But, this balance is very delicate, for instance,
in the case of milk and cherries, this happens.
And, during that time, the simulator creates
a beautiful bent liquid surface that is truly
a sight to behold.
Once again, all of this footage is simulated
on a computer.
The fact that this new work can simulate these
three physical systems and their interactions
is a true miracle.
Absolutely incredible.
Now, if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, squeeze that paper, because we will
now do my favorite thing in any simulation
paper, and that is when we let reality be
our judge, and compare the simulated results
to real life footage.
This is a photograph.
And now comes the simulation.
Whoa.
I have to say, if no one told me which is
which, I might not be able to tell.
And I am delighted to no end by this fact,
so much so that I had to ask the authors to
double-check if this really is a simulation
and they managed to reproduce the illumination
of these scenes so perfectly.
Yes they did!
Fantastic attention to detail.
Very impressive.
So, how long do we have to wait for all this?
For a 2 dimensional scene, it pretty much
runs interactively, that is great news.
And, we are firmly in the seconds per frame
region for the 3D scenes, but look, the Boat
and Leaves scene runs in less than two seconds
per time step.
That is absolutely amazing.
Not real time, because one frame contains
several time steps, but why would it be real
time?
That this is the kind of paper that makes
something previously impossible possible,
and it even does that swiftly.
I would wager, we are just one, or at most,
two more papers away from getting this in
real time.
This is unbelievable progress in just one
paper.
And all handcrafted, no learning algorithms
anywhere to be seen.
Huge congratulations to the authors.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!